heute zurück in köln wir kurse jetzt
hier durch den flug oder so nicht
einfach die letzten ich nehme diesen
roller jetzt immer mit wenn ich hier
grünen flieger was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich starte das ganze heute mal aus
seiner perspektive von irgendwie da oben
weil ich wollte es einfach mal
ausprobieren ich weiß dass sie anders
gewohnt aber ihr könnt ja gerne in die
kommentare schreiben ob das auch okay
ist weil ich finde eigentlich gar nicht
mal schlecht da muss ich hier nicht
immer so eine ganze provisorisch ecke
aufbau wo ich dann die kamera drauf
stehen kann wenn ihr versteht was ich
meine
auf jeden fall kam er vor ein paar tagen
das 24 stunden bahnhof essen experiment
wo ich halt am bahnhof essen ausprobiert
habe und geschaut auch okay wie teuer
ist das um es dann halt jetzt in diesem
video mit flughafen essen zwar gleich
das ganze videos eigentlich schon
abgedreht bevor es losgeht weil ich
allerdings sagen also in dem video bin
ich halt nach berlin geflogen und wieder
zurück das heißt ich war zweimal am
flughafen an zwei verschiedenen tagen
weil ich halt für einen tag nach berlin
musste und es war wirklich sehr sehr
schwer in 24 stunden halt drei
verschiedene mahlzeiten gegen die vom
flughafen zu kaufen und zu schauen okay
wie teuer wird das jeweils auch in
berlin der flughafen ist ein bisschen
außerhalb und das habe ich zeitlich
einfach nicht geschafft trotzdem haben
wir einmal frühstück mittagessen und
abendessen und das zusammenaddiert hat
eine schöne summe ergeben ich war in
einem restaurant ich war bei einem
bäcker ich war in einem einkaufsladen
alles am flughafen auch immer hinter dem
security check all das werde ich schon
alles verstehen ich wünsche euch viel
spaß mit dem video ihr könnt ihr gerne
jetzt mal kommentieren was glaubt ihr
wie viel geld habe ich am ende bezahlen
müssen schreibt in die kommentare und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß
metzger ich weiß das gewinde ein
bisschen hektisch so aber ich hatte
irgendwie das keine zeit vor ein paar
tagen haben wir das video 24
dass ich auch noch das ganze mit
flughafen lassen vor ort einfach um so
einen kleinen vergleich zu schaffen was
ist eurer bahnhof oder flughafen ich
habe ja erst mal gesagt flughafen
wir werden sehen und ihr habt euch das
ja auch wirklich sehr oft in den
kommentaren gewinnen und das bietet sich
jetzt halt an weil ich jetzt für zwei
tage nach berlin fliegen befallen es
erst mal los
in einer stunde ist nämlich schon
boarding und das darf ich nicht
verpassen und habe ich ein großes
problem
[Musik]
okay okay leute angekommen in köln am
flughafen ich muss sagen also das parken
ist hier wirklich so scheiße ich bin
wirklich schon öfter von hier geflogen
und immer wieder bin ich eben spa wird
und wann sie irgendwo wo es dann nicht
weitergeht oder ich vielleicht liegt
hier ein paar mir durch waren eindruck
war ich bin nur einen tag da aber das
lustige ist ich habe einfach auch noch
so ein roller dabei weil ich so einen
roller hersteller in berlin und den
roller soll ich mitnehmen mit dem roller
war ich auch noch nie am flughafen aber
ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
so orte zu dann würde ich mal sagen ab
geht's ich glaub dir nehme ich jetzt
immer mit so auf jeden fall ganz
entspannt die frage ist dann aber
natürlich darf ich am flughafen damit
auch um kunst
die leute kommen habe ich jetzt
abgegeben und jetzt jetzt in security
check was wir kommen rein natürlichen
dollar 380 solar jetzt schauen wir mal
ob man noch irgendwas zu essen finden
weil keine bundes bisschen kleiner als
15 04 10 ich denke ein paar sachen
finden aber das sieht doch schon mal gut
aus
naja ist ein bisschen teurer als am
bahnhof alter von 4 50
[Musik]
so leute aufgegessen ich habe nur 720
gekostet und jetzt geht es zu bei 80 da
ist nämlich mein geld
es soll weitere angekommen in berlin
das muss ich erstmal meine rolle
wiederfinden dann morgen so leute was
geht ab schöne grüße aus berlin
wir haben jetzt leider schon den
nächsten tag gestern wenn ich am
flughafen angekommen und hatte dann
wirklich überhaupt keine zeit mehr
irgendwas aufzunehmen das ist dann halt
das schwierig an dieser challenge weil
ja ich kann jetzt auch nicht 24 sondern
immer irgendwie am flughafen stellen
zumal ich mir halt auch noch gedacht
habe um es jetzt möglichst realistisch
zu halten und es dann vielleicht auch
mit diesem bahnhofs experiment zu
vergleichen macht es ja sind immer nur
hinter dem security checks zu essen also
wenn man halt durch die
sicherheitsschleuse geht danach gibt's
ja auch eine menge restaurants die dann
meistens noch teurer sind weil die
bleibt halt wirklich du kannst ja nicht
mehr zurückgehen
deswegen würde ich sagen wir machen es
jetzt so diese 24 stunden schicht kann
man halt in diesem fall nicht wenig
einheiten
trotzdem pflege ich ja heute abend
zurück und dann schauen wir mal das war
ein abendessen bekommen und dann hat
noch das frühstück garantieren wir dass
und gucken mal wie teuer es wird und
dann kann man es ja vergleichen also
seid ihr da bitte nicht allzu böse
trotzdem zeige ich euch noch mal schnell
hier die aussicht ich weiß nicht
vielleicht kennen das ja einige von euch
da oben ist sogar auch noch der
fernsehturm kann man ganz leicht sehen
war auf jeden fall ganz nah dran
ich finde ich immer eine gute
alternative von ich muss mich jetzt
beeilen weil ich habe heute einen dreher
in berlin und wir sehen uns dann heute
abend im flughafen wieder
in berlin am flughafen immer noch
betroffen was geht und jetzt geht's hier
ins restaurant einmal bist du sicher
dass ich nicht in dieser s-bahn gehen
das ist jetzt für mich oder ja
wahrscheinlich heute im angebot
ja zweimal die pasta und einmal noch so
ein bisschen salat dazu
[Musik]
und da hier drauf weiß nicht wie sie
vielleicht einfach nur still pluspunkt
oder wenn es exakt an die nation
[Gelächter]
ohne tomaten betrifft
juli heißt ok cola kommt noch so leute
also einmal hier
der salat und noch nudeln die nudeln
haben zwölf euro 50 gekostet und der
salat eigentlich 590 also insgesamt
bestimmt 20 euro das gute ist nur der
salat schon weggelaufen
heute hat uns empfohlen wir besser nicht
zuerst nicht schmeckt aber ich mache es
okay also feiern natürlich an zu fragen
der salat war aber auch ganz neu ist
oder wer also mal nicht nur auf weil ich
habe
das ist nicht wie heute zurück in köln
wir kurse jetzt hier durch den flug oder
so nicht einfach die letzten ich nehme
diesen roller jetzt immer mit wenn ich
irgendwo hinfliegen
du bist extrem einfach perfekt wir
müssen auf jeden fall dass wir daraus
glaube ich müsste nur hier raus leute
auf jeden fall so ich mache ich mir noch
ein brötchen teilnehmer für morgen früh
damit auch die preis verhältnisse weiter
stimmen
allerdings muss man jetzt auch schon wie
kann das geklappt weil wir hier zum halb
elf waren ja also wir sehen uns
vielleicht sollte ich gehe mal kurz nach
dem rewe einkaufen weil hier am
flughafen gibt es im revier ich hatte
eigentlich gedacht hier ist auch alles
doppelt so teuer aber ist gar nicht so
ok
[Musik]
leute was geht herzlich willkommen
zurück ich muss leider sagen gestern als
simon und ich am flughafen angekommen
sind ist meine kamera ausgegangen also
ich war doch gerade im supermarkt am
flughafen und dann war vorbei mein handy
ball also ich hatte gar keine
möglichkeiten wir irgendwas aufzunehmen
aber jetzt glaube ich noch gesehen was
gekauft habe und zwar war das einmal
hier der smoothie den ich auch am
bahnhof gekauft habt am flughafen wieder
30 cent teurer diese karte solle für nur
49 cent am flughafen fand ich schon
krass oder noch so brutschin kosten und
brezel von denen nicht alles wissen die
briten auch gegessen hat heute früh
studiert hier ich euch gerne nochmal die
summe die ich dafür bezahlt habe und es
so auf jeden fall extrem lustig gestern
am flughafen wir sind angekommen sind
wir müssen uns gut an euch den ganzen
flughafen
wir hatten auch nicht mehr so viel zeit
das ist eben es heftig gegen seine tür
gefahren hier irgendwie nicht gesehen
hat ja und irgendwann war ich dann auch
wieder hier und konnten die schlafen
weil ich war auch sehr müde und trotzdem
was wirklich sehr cool ich muss sagen
über den preis ging jetzt am ende raus
haben will ich ein bisschen überrascht
ich hatte gedacht es wird noch teurer
natürlich muss man sagen das restaurant
war schon sehr teuer da habe ich würde
einen salat die nudeln und die cola
etwas über 21 euro für mich alleine
bezahlt er sollte bei allen restaurants
knapp über der hälfte liegen
aber der rest ging eigentlich voll klar
also ich persönlich jetzt eigentlich
deutlich teurer eingestuft ich glaube
wir hatten jetzt so eine differenz von
ungefähr sechs euro zudem bartz
experiment das könnt ihr euch sehr gerne
doch anschauen schreibt weitere ideen
für 20 stunden schon ist in die
kommentare
und das war es von mir wir sehen uns
haut rein